delain game certainly has the potential
to dissipate excitement for even the
most anticipated of titles game swats
people's choice for most exciting game
of e3 2013 watchdog certainly lost a few
fans when it announced its delays but I
think there's at least one reason to
keep excitement up for the title in fact
I've got five let's get into them the
first reason on my list is the chance to
get stuck into another of Ubisoft
typically excellent in the world we
recently had a feature from Daniel Hines
on site which suggested that watch dogs
is all set to deliver exactly what we've
expected from Ubisoft's open-world
plenty to explore crafting as well as
random and not so random encounters with
so many linear cinematic titles and
games that pretend to be open world but
mostly take place in giant cages I'm
looking at your tomb raider it's nice
that Ubisoft is doing their part to give
game as a place to room and make their
own choices a feature we don't see
nearly enough of in games is hacking a
mechanic that watch dogs could certainly
capitalize on by incorporating clever
and tactical hacking with the focus in
many games shifting towards hack and
slash and belting bullets into enemies
there's a real satisfaction in being
offered another path to the final win
scenario whether that part happens to
involve stealth or in this case hacking
it's a seriously refreshing way of
tackling an in-game obstacle obviously
this is pretty dependent on how Ubisoft
decide to actually implement the
mechanic but if the choices are varied
and unique enough as we're expecting
them to be this is a particularly
exciting feature I know I've said it a
hundred times before but generally I
find multiplayer in games pretty tedious
and would much rather just get stuck
into a single player campaign then again
that dislike is not so prominent when it
comes to multiplayer that pushes beyond
the typical watch dogs is planning to
implement multiplayer in a way that not
only makes sense in the world but also
changes up to
sick player versus player formula
essentially it boils down to another
player secretly slipping into your
single player game or vice versa then
the infiltrator is tasked with finding
the other player in their game and then
attempting to install a backdoor virus
in the players phone to extract data
which then transfers to power in their
own single player game if they return to
it and complete their objective
successfully for me then nothing all
that exciting about attacked on
multiplayer mode but something that
works with the game's concept and
contribute back to your single-player
campaign is an interesting idea let me
know what you think of the mode you're
pretty hard pressed to find an in-game
story these days that doesn't sound
eerily similar to a whole lot of other
games you've already played but watch
dogs may be one of those gems not to
mention incredibly topical since you're
hard pressed to find a newspaper these
days that doesn't mention the NSA watch
dogs is all about information warfare
sure the city's all-seeing central
operating system can track you using
technology but that's not to say you
can't use it to your advantage to and
being that you happen to play a super
smart hack savvy Irish vigilante that
complements your skillset pretty well in
what I consider something of a blessing
we haven't been horribly inundated with
Ubisoft telling us all about the plot
just yet so hopefully the concept is
just as enjoyable in its execution as it
is enticing in its potential this was
the game that was gonna make me buy a
ps4 I wanted next-gen graphics on a game
that sounded this good and then there
were leagues Jake got pulled and my
plans for buying a next-generation
console was pretty much scrapped so
let's call this one a reason for buying
a ps4 obviously loads of you have
already taken the current gen plunge
with a ps4 or an xbox one button given I
play most of my games on my pc I really
did need a little incentive even though
watchdog is making its way to PC having
a game good enough to experience on a
new generation console and show off what
it can do is great I'm a firm believer
that it takes software to sell hardware
and the idea of a sprawling urban
metropolis
to explore on my TV with the shiny new
console is hard to pass up let me know
what's exciting you about watch dogs
already think there's another upcoming
title we should be focusing on you can
leave me your thoughts either in the
comments down below or on my twitter
where you can find me at just mcdonald
i'll be back next week chatting about
another topic so I'll see you then
you